[Musique]
et une sorte de deux mystères on peut
regarder par exemple une série
complètement débile et sans intérêt et
se souvenir de tout et puis ensuite
quand on se retrouve face à un cours de
mathématiques face à des informations de
la presse ou des magazines spécialisés
en psychologie un ep avoir des
difficultés à les mémoriser
qu'est ce qui fait que quelque chose de
bête et méchant c'est raté fascine et
quelque chose de plus à dire de plus
profond de plus technique a de plus
exigeant ça devient difficile alors garé
là plusieurs pistes qu'on peut pas voir
pour comprendre ça d'abord c'est que
quand on regarde une série un peu il ya
tourné mais comme c'est un peu un peu
fasciné on pense à rien on est
complètement focus finalement sur sur
l'écran dès lors marquer quand on
regarde la télévision série c'est un
petit peu comme si tous disparaissait ya
plus que l'écran qui existent on en fait
toujours l'expérience que ce soit sur
smartphone la télévision et puis
l'émission de temps de parasitage des
réputations dire que si on commence à
vouloir mémoriser quelque chose en se
disant je suis pas je surfais pas y
aller toutes ses dates à retenir il ya
tous ces équations et toutes ces
informations parce que je veux faire un
terrain on arrive avec une lassitude et
un manque de confiance en soi énorme qui
perturbe énormément là
mémorisation le secret pour bien
mémoriser les simples c'est être focus
concentré être calme pour avoir minimum
de rumination l'associer avec des
émotions en fait parce que quand on
associe une information une émotion elle
reste davantage
alors pour prendre un exemple simple de
cela pendant comme par exemple on est
traumatisé par un accident une rupture
un deuil bien ce sont des choses qui
nous marque et qui reste très durement
inscrit dans notre mémoire et puis si ce
sont des événements très très curieux
aussi une naissance mariage ou autre
pareil cela reste fortement présent dans
notre mémoire dont plus on a des motions
associé à quelque chose que l'on retient
cette chose et puis aussi plus associé à
des images
des sensations et des sons et +1 retient
l'information alors là c'est en ce qu'on
va faire va vous permettre de retenir
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'informations à la suite
et tout ça sans fournir le moindre
effort donc c'est très très confortable
vous trouverez d'ailleurs des des mp3
gratuit sur le site étroite de séance
d'hypnose sur le site city raconte je
pourrais faire également cette séance
d'hypnose sur ma chaîne youtube
slash et coaching et puis vous trouverez
sur toute une collection plus d'une
vingtaine de séances d'hypnose sur le
site figaro lève avec qui ne créions
cette collection d'hypnose très très
pratique vous servir au quotidien pour
permettre d'être calme de bien dormir
peu d'être serein dans toutes les
circonstances me le but ou essaient de
d'échapper des séances d'hypnose
complexe et d'être dans quelque chose
qui vous sera utile au jour le jour où
une sorte de boîte à outils si vous
voulez alors la séance d'hypnose qu'on
va faire aujourd'hui s'inspirent
directement d'une méthode très ancien il
s'agit du palais de la mémoire qu'on
appelait auparavant la méthode des lots
qui n'atteint les méthodes des lieux
c'est une méthode très ancienne puisque
tout de même la première référence qu'on
trouvait dans 82 après jésus-christ et
c'est un poète simeoni de ces hausses
qui ont inventé mais en tout cas aurait
été le premier en parler cette méthode
qui toute l'antiquité puisque des
personnages aussi c'est la preuve que
quintilien aussi serre ont également
utilisé puisque saint thomas d'aquin qui
a eu droit et je nage un impact
extraordinaire sur la philosophie la
pensée du moyen-âge également utiliser
et cette énigme à nous est arrivé elle
est encore utilisée elle a cet avantage
extraordinaire de pouvoir garder un
maximum d'informations techniques
précises avec un minimum d'effort vous
avez la découvrir au fur et à mesure de
la séance d'hypnose
sachez que l'idée est très simple c'est
de se construire un palais de la mémoire
c'est à dire de par exemple prendre les
pièces de sa maison dans son esprit est
d'associer à chaque information un objet
une idée qui va leur transfert si par
exemple vous les souvenirs de de
marignan en 15/100 15 et bien vous allez
imaginez par exemple votre chambre et
sur le bureau de votre chambre
le chiffre 15 115 et peut-être un poster
où il sera marquée marignan et où vous
aurez un tableau de françois 1er pour
pouvoir vous en souvenir plus facilement
l'idée c'est d'associer une information
un lieu
et de lui donner une réalité sensorielle
de par une passe de marignan 15 115 qui
est un peu rébarbatif cette date
évidemment tout la connaît mais à
quelque chose de beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus sensorielle est associé à un lieu
et quand dans votre esprit vous
visiterez la chambre et bien vous allez
retrouver automatiquement les
informations et il n'y a presque pas de
limite à ce que l'on peut intégrer grâce
à ça alors avec l'hypnose ça va être
encore plus facile vous n'aurez pas
d'effort à fournir et tout va se faire
tout seul donc c'est très pratique
alors petite précaution il faut que vous
appreniez d'abord votre cours les
informations que vous devez retenir
et puis ensuite seulement faire la
séance d'hypnose pour que toutes ces
informations qui sont enregistrés à
court terme à ce moment là soit
enregistrée ensuite à long terme et dans
une exhaustivité quasi complète
alors comme pour chaque séance d'hypnose
installez vous confortablement
rien ne vous empêche d'être allongée si
vous préférez rester assis à votre
bureau
quelque part ou être dans son fauteuil
confortable évidemment ça ne pose aucun
problème et puis cette sympathique nous
sommes bien mieux vécu
avec des écouteurs puisque nous sommes
en train d'enregistrer cette séance avec
ce qu'on appelle un système binaural
c'est-à-dire deux micros qui permettent
d'enregistrer les sons comme si vous y
étiez
je peux parler à une oreille d'un côté
puis à à l'autre oreille et l'intérêt
c'est de vous plonger dans une
expérience encore plus immersive à et
donc de vous permettre de vivre encore
davantage la séance d'hypnose
et puis vous verrez c'est très agréable
à vivre alors commencé à fixer un point
l'idée c'est de s'abstraire de
l'extérieur et puis simplement regarder
le avec un regard doux il ya toujours
cette idée de de recueillement quand on
fait une séance d'hypnose
un peu comme dans la méditation
d'ailleurs et simplement regarder ce
point sa couleur sa luminosité laissez
vous porter par me voir son sens plus
d'exigence que cela j'espère que vous
aurez compris au travers de l'exemple
que je donnais tout à l'heure que
finalement quand on est passif est
réceptif c'est le moment où on mémorise
le mieux alors prêté attention à ma voix
comme si je vous raconter une histoire
et puis laissez vous porter il n'y a pas
d'efforts à faire à certains moments
même certains mots vont vous échapper ce
fait exprès pour que vous puissiez un
peu décroché parce que il n'ya rien de
pire lorsque l'on veut apprendre quelque
chose que de se concentrer trop et à
cause de cela de se fatiguer de
décrocher si on lit un texte 4 x 5 x on
peut être sûr qu'on ne le retiendra pas
le but donc c'est ce que vous allez
obtenir ces dates dans une sorte de
passivité douce et réceptive et c'est ce
que les plaintes soit vous permettre
d'obtenir puisque lorsque vous faites
une séance d'hypnose vous êtes presque
totalement centrée sur la voie et
lorsqu'on est dans cet état d'où qu'on
appelle la transe eh bien on vit tous
avec plus d'intensité c'est un peu comme
si
en coupant les sens extérieur les sens
intérieur devenait plus fort plus
présents comme si en arrêtant de se
centrer sur l'extérieur la vie
intérieure se renforcer avec elle sa
capacité à nous toucher nous faire
changer évoluer
et puis avec l'hypnose cette chose un
peu mystérieux ce qui est un travail sur
l'inconscient que vous allez pouvoir
observer ne serait-ce que en étant plus
calmes tout à l'heure vous serez
beaucoup plus détendu plus confiants
aussi et sans avoir à fournir d'efforts
c'est ce qui est assez assez incroyable
avec l'hypnose c'est cette action sur
l'inconscient que vous sentirez de plus
en plus de de séance en séance et dans
le décompte de 5 un peu importe le
moment vous fermez les yeux ça arrivera
peut-être très rapidement ou bien un peu
un peu plus tard ensuite peut-être
chiffre serait peut-être au chiffre 1
dans le décompte que je souhaite faire
écouter les bruits autour de vous c'est
pourriez qui vous accompagner en transe
puis surtout au fur et à mesure vous
traversez davantage d'abord faire partie
du paysage de vos sensations et plus
certainement au fur et à mesure diminuer
jusqu'à disparaître et pendant qu'une
partie de vous consciente observe
analyse et se pose tout à fait
légitimement la question de l'efficacité
de cette séance est bien une autre
partie est partie inconsciente en vous
déjà simplement parce que vous êtes
porté par ma voix que vous accordez un
temps de repos vous est posée bien
confortable
et bien cette partie inconsciente déjà
met en place une sorte d'intériorisation
un processus qui se manifeste par une
respiration plus lente et régulière que
vous pouvez observer et aussi des
sensations du corps plus précise
ça peut être tout à fait par exemple les
sensations de l'air contre le visage de
l'air contre les mains du roi déboires
du poids des jambes
en fait le le regard passe de
l'extérieur de cette sorte d' analyse
humains d'efforts r un regard intérieur
beaucoup plus doux un peu plus passifs
aussi mais surtout un peu plus léger
agréable et ce quelque chose de tout à
fait naturel comme lorsqu'on est
absorbée par exemple dans la
contemplation d'un film où ce moment
assez agréable lorsqu'on étudie que l'on
ressent comme lorsque l'on court une
sorte de deuxième s'ouvre quand on court
au départ
et toujours cette fatigue au début sorte
de fatigue consciente un effort à
fournir puis à un moment très agréable
où on passe de cette fatigue à un second
souffle et on oublie d'être fatigué
n'oubliez de penser et c'est
certainement entre autres ceux qui
paient autant personne qui kiffent 1 du
sport ce moment où on passe du conscient
à quelque chose d'inconscient et
d'ailleurs quand on fait du sport
et bien tout naturellement se met en
transe et
et les bénéfices de cette transe reste
bien longtemps après et c'est un peu la
même magie qui opère lorsque vous
regardez un ordinateur
la télévision vos cours au départ une
sorte de petit effort à faire et au bout
d'un moment il ne reste plus que la
lecture du coup il ne reste plus que
l'écran tout le reste
disparaît et on se met dans une sorte de
réceptivité inconsciente
on laisse les informations s'écrire en
eau comme si nous étions une sorte de
livre de cahiers aux dans les pages sol
vierge et les informations cqeer est
tout seul sous forme de l'image de son
de sensations et aussi est aussi
d'émotion et chaque personne a une
manière différente de penser certaines
personnes comme moi ont surtout avec des
sons l'on parle plutôt de d'intelligence
auditive d'autres personnes total le
soap servent à manière de penser et
remarquent qu'elles sont plutôt marqué
par les images c'est comme ça que
retiennent mieux et puis d'autres
personnes observent que finalement ce
temps faisons des gestes en
s'appropriant les sensations qu'elle me
morice de mieux et là on parle de
personnes qui naissent tesic
mais ce qui est important c'est de
savoir que plus on mélange les
sensations entre de son image les
émotions et plus ses sensations
s'imprègne en vous c'est pour ça que
l'on retient beaucoup plus facilement
une bande dessinée qu'un qu'un texte
aille c'est pour ça que en général on
retient aussi beaucoup plus facilement
du film une série parce que cela mais
elle voit les images les sons les
sensations les émotions et donc cela
s'installe tout seul en nous mais cette
capacité on peut l'avoir pour tout achat
quéré pour chaque chose
il suffit d'apprendre à se mettre dans
cet état hypnotique dans lequel vous
êtes en train de vous mettre 100 sans
plus d'efforts que cela et c'est pour ça
aussi que l'hypnose est utilisé pour
développer et et apprentissage dans les
importants plus facilement
c'est comme ça que certaines personnes
par exemple utilisent l'hypnose pour
apprendre les langues ou pour par
exemple les sportives pour ceux
programmés à l'avancé mettre en place
des changements dans la tranquillité de
leur inconscient encore plus sûrement
que s'il le faisait sur le terrain et
c'est ce qu'on appelle la préparation
mentale et d'air à propos de
préparations mentales observées comme
vous êtes déjà sur un mode beaucoup plus
inconscients beaucoup plus tranquille
vous sentez le contact de l'air contre
le visage le contact de l'air contre les
bas et puis cette progression douce la
relaxation vers la transe et comme nous
et émotionnels sont très liés à la
respiration
quand on a du mal à mémoriser quand on
se bloque sur quelque chose la
respiration à l'eau si ce bloc devient
plus courant tandis que lorsqu'on est
dans un bon rythme la respiration
devient plus profonde plus calme vous
savez quand quelqu'un joue un jeu de
société ou à une activité qui donnait un
peu de concentration les mots fléchés de
ce dock ou roumains porte à un moment la
respiration devient vraiment très
profonde et souvent on entend beaucoup
mieux leur respiration et l'extérieur
parfois ça ressemble presque
soto un de ronflements de cas de
respiration d'un dormeur et c'est pour
ça je vous invite à prendre deux
inspirations profondes
une première à pine secondes et à
laisser votre respiration ce profonde
hier tout seul
et pendant que les pensées s'accroche et
se décrochent pendant que les pensées se
font et se défont
ce fort recul se déforme forme d'autres
formes d'autres sous forme autre
inspiration elle devient plus profonde
cru cannes vous pouvez sentir cet air
calme vrai que vous inspirez sentir de
quelle manière je diffuse en vous comme
des terrains ci ne calment un peu de la
même manière courront les informations
tout à l'heure à s'installer en vous de
dire simplement drôle s'écrire en vous
comme si vous étiez un papier prêt à
recevoir les écritures
tout ce que vous avez à prendre pour que
vous puissiez entrées de plus en plus en
transe 4 et d'autres sensations
s'installe bien sûr à main le poids de
l'aspiration inspiration plus profonde
plus landes lourd de sync et ceci le le
poids du corps
j'aime bien cette idée de poids du corps
par des bras de la tête elle même le
poids des paupières droit de tout ce
corps qui se détendent plus en plus en
transe
c'est une manière de laisser partir nos
rumination trois autobus à vassieux
pourra se diriger vers une réceptivité
entière un peu comme ces moments
précieux lorsque l'on écoute un
professeur hors du commun un intervenant
dans l'intelligence est saisissante où
les propos ma foi intéressants ou drôles
se retrouvent suspendus à ses lèvres
avec cette impression d'être pardonné
l'otan dans le sort de passivité
réceptrice en bois littéralement les
barreaux de sa personne et ça c'est ce
que l'hypnose permet de créer au fur et
à mesure et c'est pour ça que votre
corps s'alourdit et vous pouvez
l'observer pour laisser la possibilité à
votre esprit d'être plus léger vous
pensez de s'éloigner au fur et à mesure
pour créer une sorte de blanc
progressive dans votre esprit et une
disposition de réceptivité à te présente
plus marqué et vous l'avez certainement
marquer quand on regarde la télévision
quand on s'absente dans la contemplation
de quelque chose
souvent l'impression un peu de
s'enfoncer dans le fauteuil l'impression
aussi que l'esprit plus léger non
s'absorbe dans quelque chose et c'est ce
vers quoi votre esprit est en train de
tendre le corps est un peu plus lourd
pour laisser l'esprit s'alléger dans la
détente et dans le même mouvement
l'esprit savez dans la détente pour le
ca encore s'alourdir
[Musique]
quelque chose de plus agréable de plus
confortable le corps lourd sur le
fauteuil lit lâcheuse bas par celle ci
celui ci nous sur le sol sol solidement
ancrée sur les fondations en droit vous
trouvez ces fondations ancré sur la
bible la ville solidement ancré sur la
terre à la terre ont créé dans le
système solaire le système solaire est
rentré dans la galaxie la galaxie ancrée
dans l'univers l'univers ancré dans le
temps et le temps se liguant en créant
vous entendez ce que vous en crée de
plus en plus
entrant dans une transe de plus en plus
calme aussi ce n'est pas l'univers en
tout cas c'est l'univers qui est ancré
dans le temps le temps lui en créant
vous en tout cas lorsque l'on regarde la
nuit les étoiles c'est amusant de penser
que notre rétine et bien finalement
absorbent un bris main à l'univers
infini et des étoiles qui parfois ont
déjà disparu au moment où on der garde
c'est tout l'infini de l'univers dont le
regard de celui qui prend le temps de
regarder les étoiles et finalement de
rêver aux 6 3 et à propos de rêve c'est
la main nous fait penser à cette étape
primordiale qui existe dans pas mal de
sociétés en pleine époque les sociétés
primitives et qu'on appelle maintenant
les peuples premiers et souvent lors
notamment en australie chez ceux qu'on
appelle les aborigènes entre sa gamme
âgées des amérindiens
il ya cette idée c'est à ces politiques
il faut le dire ce qu'on appelle le ton
du rêve l'idée c'est que avant ce monde
que nous connaissions où les lois les
règles de l'univers sont figés il y
avait un temps beaucoup plus souple qui
était le temps du rêve c'était un temps
les hommes pouvaient se transformer en
animaux et les animaux
en pierre les pierres en sommes et
cetera et cetera rien n'était figé tout
était dans une sorte de mutation
permanente
tout est possible les hommes même et est
immortel
et puis un moment quelque chose s'est
sclérosé s'est figé pour donner
naissance à notre temps un temps donc où
les mêmes causes créer les mêmes
conséquences
et dans cette image bien connue de ce
philosophe chinois qui qui rêvait d'être
un papillon et qui tellement pris par ce
rêve se demandaient s'ils étaient
papillon un homme qui ne veut pas moyen
de le dire que quand on rêve ou l'oubli
jusqu'à sa propre identité et bien
souvent quand on se réveille c'est un
sentiment d'étrangeté
j'étais papillon je ne suis plus
papillon je suis un homme mais que
suis-je exactement et peut-être cette
idée assez charmante dans nos rêves dans
notre imagination
nous nous reconnecter avec ce temps du
rêve justement ce temps d infinies
possible parce que lorsque mon rêve peut
être tout on peut être simple
observateur d'un rêve d'une histoire
être un autre homme une autre femme une
autre personne peut être vieux plus âgés
un peu pourquoi pas havre des pouvoirs
magiques être un super héros on peut
être absolument tout et lorsque l'on
rêve on devient complètement cet autre
chose on qu'il ya quelque chose de
mystérieux dans dans leurs rêves qu'on
retrouve aussi dans l'hypnose c'est à
dire qu'il ya une sorte de pouvoir
infini de l'imagination sans restriction
alors qu'est ce que c'est que le rêve où
va notre esprit ya ceux qui ne savent
pas qu'ils le savent
keith a donc déjà beaucoup plus que ce
qu'ils pensent savoir et qui en même
temps ne savent pas vraiment et ceux qui
savent tout ce qu'ils savent parfois non
plus envie de savoir c'est là que le
rêve en lui donne une élasticité
remarquable à l'âme est une possibilité
d'être tout être rien et de vivre en
énergie mille vies puisque chaque nuit
vous vivez me autre monde lui l'autre
vie et c'est peut-être le secret de
notre liberté que donne pas tenu à une
seule vie une seule obligation de ne pas
tout enchaîné par les causes les effets
la routine du quotidien
le rêve l'hypnose nous libère de ses
chaînes de l'habitude et nous permettent
d'apporter de la nouveauté à nos vies
alors si l'on parle de pouvoir de
l'imagination l'imagination au pouvoir
pour reprendre ce slogan et bien c'est
certainement est dans le rêve et et dans
l'it mauvaise qu'on peut le trouver
vous entrez plus intense non plus en
plus calmement
2 alors pendant que vous pensez
s'accroche se décrochent s'accroche et
ceux des granges alors que vous savez
déjà plus donc vous ne saviez que vous
saviez
alors que faire ce faisant ce faire
notre rien d'autre que l'on se fait ou
finalement peut-être ne plus faire rêver
que l'on sait faire on fait ce que l'on
rêve et dans une nouvelle liberté
infinie des choix multiples des choix
sans restriction sans limites en temps
sans obligation sans conséquence dans
une sorte de nouvelles libertés qui se
pose plus sur les choix que l'on fait au
quotidien de maman sur la capacité de
vivre et de s'imaginer toute chose sous
toutes les formes dans une sorte de
mutation permanente et d'évolution de
l'imaginaire sortes de demandes libérer
de ses chaînes qu'est celui du rêve de
l'imagination
1 les yeux déjà fermé ou à faire mais
maintenant c'est dans une transe
agréable et simplement le fait d'écouter
m'avoir et de vous laisser porter par
votre respiration
simplement grâce à cela votre trans
outre état hypnotique va pouvoir
s'approfondir et s'approfondir a
d'ailleurs de plus en plus à mesure que
vous répéterez cette séance où d'autres
séances que nous proposons et cela vous
permettra à chaque fois d'entrer plus
facilement plus rapidement en france et
même parfois d'anticiper mes paroles
pour commencer le travail et boutiques
dès que vous êtes prêt sera aussi cette
facilité au fur et à mesure de pouvoir
utiliser ce ballet de la mémoire à votre
compte et spontanément même en dehors
des séances
même si évidemment les séances d'hypnose
ou permettront de l'imprimé encore plus
fortement durablement et facilement en
fait je vous invite à les faire avec une
grande régularité pour repas après
chacune de vos séances d'étude pourquoi
pas le soir avant de s'endormir pour que
les informations saint prime un
doublement puisque d'importants
simplement s'est entraînée l'esprit
lorsqu'on oublie l'esprit peut
s'entraîner exactement comme un muscle
on peut s'entraîner au calme sans
traîner la concentration on peut
s'entraîner la sérénité au bonheur même
à la créativité
il faut apprendre à considérer son
cerveau comme une sorte de muscles on a
le droit de travailler qui vous
permettra d'être toujours mieux on vous
même et aussi peut-être d'avoir une
sorte de fierté sur le trap fait
accompli
c'est vrai que de l'extérieur et chaud
soupe ça vaut moins qu'un travail
physique mais de l'intérieur
c'est peut-être ce travail sur soi le
seul travail qui est vraiment de
l'importance
peut-être baston sa vie à vouloir être
vraiment soit mam et à le devenir je ne
sais pas en tout cas ce que je sais
c'est que dans cette recherche
intérieure
je trouve sinon les clés notre bonheur
en tout cas les clés de notre sérénité
l'impression que mon avance avec un
sentiment de sens plus en plus précis et
ce besoin de sens que nous avons tous et
bien je vous invitais à cultiver au
travers de toutes les séances que nous
proposons pendant que les pensées
s'accrochent des granges paccot se
décrochent s'accroche
ce dekra tandis que de la mutation des
pensées des idées dans seuls qui vont
viennent
cette manière car le cerveau
d'enregistrer davantage quand ils
arrêtent de soute observé devoir penser
c'est à dire qu'un certain moment on
oublie d'écouté et pourtant on entend
tout et pourtant tous imprimant vous est
certainement quelque chose de mystérieux
lorsque l'on se croyait dans les mines
et que finalement la tour tenu une
conversation émotions en fait mon
registre toujours beaucoup plus
d'informations qu'on ne me croie
mais les paroles de confiance de
rumination nous empêche habituellement
de parvenir à toutes ses richesses
l'hypnose contourne tout se bat
et c'est pour ça aussi que mon petit tu
n'oses retrouver ce qu'on appelle un
sentiment d'ipernity c'est à dire la
capacité à retrouver des souvenirs que
l'on croyait enfouie dont on ignorait
jusqu'à l'existence et ça c'est aussi
quelque chose d'assez extraordinaire
observé à la fois quand ton et le
patient dans un cabinet de psy mais
aussi pour le psy quand le psy autres
adlib ne se rencontrent que notre
inconscient et quelque chose de
bienveillant et qu'il a en lui des
ressources que finalement nous ne
connaissons pas où nous oublions fur et
à mesure l'inconscient la possibilité de
se souvenir d'énormément de choses
l'inconscient la possibilité de vous
apprendre à être bien inconscient la
possibilité de vous permettre de ne pas
souffrir
l'inconscient la possibilité de nous
transformer de nous faire évoluer
et si déjà et fait un travail formidable
en nous apportant des que l'on pense pas
tout la sécurité ou le bien-être que
nous pouvons avoir chaque jour eh bien
il a d'autres ressources d'autres
réservés ces séances sont là pour vous
permettre de les expérimenter
j'aimerais ça comment maintenant
demander à votre esprit inconscient de
choisir le doigt qui correspond le plus
à la réponse oui j'étais qu'il aura
choisi se doivent à pouvoir se lever un
petit geste inconscient et presque par
essieu très bien c'est suffisant je vais
demander maintenant à votre esprit
inconscient de vous faire vivre
l'endroit où vous habitez votre maison
ou votre appartement
je voulais vivre autant dans le détail
le connaissez parfaitement cette
angoisse pour ça que si il fait nuit
vous arrivez à vous déplacer
c'est un endroit que vous associez avec
une émotion de sécurité la familiarité
évidemment c'est ce qui fait que lorsque
l'on change d'appartement ou de maison
débat n'a pas l'impression d'être chez
soi c'est quelque chose qui se construit
au fur à mesure jusqu'à ce que vraiment
notre chez-nous devienne une extension
de qui nous sommes
notre territoire est aussi un reflet de
nos personnalités dans la décoration
dans les choix que nous pouvons faire
peut-être même dans la manière d'être
organisés désorganisé il ya évidemment
énormément de nous dans nos chez nous et
vous allez pouvoir dans un premier temps
vous déplacer chez vous et observer
toutes ces pièces se chambrent même si
c'est juste un studio
cela n'a pas d'importance nous n'avons
pas besoin pour le ballet de la mémoire
d'avoir beaucoup de pièces jeu seul
suffit c'est très bien
prenez le temps de rentrer dans votre
univers de rentrer dans ce lieu que vous
appelez la maison et vous promener je
vais demander à votre esprit inconscient
installé dans chacune des pièces aussi
petite soit elle
un tableau noir ou un tableau blanc
comme vous préférez qui nous servira
plus tard inscrire les informations
importantes
m
maintenant je vais demander à votre
esprit inconscient de commencer à se
souvenir de toutes les informations
vraiment importante que devait
enregistrer en vous et dès qu'il aura
commencé à vous faire vous souvenir dans
l'ordre de ces informations importantes
celles qui sont les plus essentiels ces
informations qui permettent de retrouver
d'autres informations
ces informations que vous avez surlignés
en quelque sorte dans votre esprit
souligné en tout cas je vais le laisser
deux minutes dès qu'ils meurent a fait
le signe oui pour nous indiquer qu'il
commence ce travail je vais laisser deux
minutes vous pour vous permettre de vous
souvenir et je veux lui demander de
mettre chacune de ces informations sous
la forme d'un moule est pas une c'est un
gros point suffit d informations les
plus résumé possible alors que déjà en
vous saint-prime comme une sorte de
liste très clair une fiche très clair
avec les informations vous avez intégré
mais ce n'est pas avant s'il en manque
certaines puisque je vous progresserait
dans cette séance d'hypnose plus les
choses se feront au niveau inconscient
marée des informations qu'ils auront
besoin de surgir surgiront tout seul
retard d'équipement a fait le signe oui
je laisserais deux ronds minutes
très bien pour faire la liste
maintenant que les informations
importantes ont été listés en vous tels
les fiches remarquablement bien fait
quand vous prenez le temps de flâner un
petit peu dans votre chez vous et puis
associé cette sensation familière de
voiliers de sécurité de protection avec
un petit geste comme nous serrer le
pouce contre l'index l'idée c'est à
chaque fois que vous utiliserez cette
méthode aller la mémoire c'est
facilement grâce à ce geste retrouver à
la fois cette sensation d'intériorité
d'intériorisation et et de retrouver
encore plus facilement
en termes d'émotion images de lieux et
bien la sensation de votre foyer
c'est très bien maintenant vous pouvez
arrêter ce petit ancrage vous pourrez le
dise à n'importe quel moment pour vous
retrouver chez vous et consulter les
informations bien on rajouter d'autres
vous verrez ça devient assez
automatiques quoi bout d'un moment et
pour que votre inconscience eux figure
qu'elle travaille fort si par exemple
votre inconscient devait retenir la
bataille de marignan qui pourrait par
exemple dans l'une des pièces de votre
maison de votre appartement y placer
françois 1er avec ses 2 mètres de haut
sur un cheval sur lequel par exemple il
y aurait le chiffre le nombre 15 115
marqué c'est peut-être le drapeau se
posant à cette époque si je ne me prend
pas il s'agissait des suisses dont se
serait par exemple un cheval avec
françois 1er et son béret pourquoi pas
le vent le glaive et avec sur le dos du
cheval
un drapeau suisse et ces chiffres 15 115
et si vous faites cela il vous suffira
de revenir dans cette pièce et vous
verrez que très facilement
l'image de ce roi sur son cheval à date
tout cela va revenir très très
facilement même si d'habitude vous avez
du mal à retenir les dates où les
numéros de téléphone pour toutes
informations chiffrées
cela va être très très facile pour à
parce que il y aura des images il y aura
peut-être même du son il y aura une
sensation des sensations et cela sera
lié un lieu si donc ce travail que je
vais demander à votre esprit intentions
et lui demander de talent et de pièce en
pièce et pour chaque information que
vous devez retenir de les illustrer avec
statut une image un objet le moyen mémo
technique qui sera le plus facile à
retenir c'est une sorte simplement
illustration et puis une fois qu'il aura
fait cela pour une information il pourra
dans cette pièce sur le tableau noir où
le tableau blanc
eh bien il pourra écrire l'information
en question est celle ci aussi
s'inscrire à durablement vous et je vais
laisser trois minutes à votre esprit
inconscient pour faire ce travail dans
toutes les pièces de votre maison vous
serez certainement surpris de voir à
quelle vitesse il peut le faire au
départ un peu lentement le temps de s'y
habituer et bien ensuite de plus en plus
rapidement cela va devenir un processus
presque totalement inconscient et donc
je vais vous accompagner en silence
pendant trois minutes le temps que votre
maison ou votre appartement ce décor de
tout ce que vous allez pouvoir retenir
je vous accompagne un silence
c'est très bien maintenant je vous
invitais sortir et derrière la porte
d'entrée
vous allez trouver un autre palais
peut-être un manoir à châteaufort
quelque chose qui sera l'expression de
votre inconscient peut-être le rêve de
ce que pourrait être une maison pour
vous peut-être s'agit-il simplement
d'une belle maison près de la mer d'être
un seul est quelque part perdu dans la
montagne d'être un château de condé est
un château fort du moyen-âge mystérieux
et sept autres ballets permettra de
stocker d'autres informations et aussi
d'associer ces informations davantage de
plaisir car plus on apprend avec plaisir
et plus les informations restent c'est
pour ça qu'il est aussi important
lorsqu'on est professeur
de créer une bonne ambiance de classe de
créer de l'émulation de la stimulation
de créer de l'enthousiasmé
donc ce nouveau palais de la mémoire et
là vous donner davantage de plaisir de
satisfaction de calme et vous donnez
aussi d'autres pièces dans lesquelles
pouvoir stocker les informations dont
vous avez besoin
je vous invite simplement à franchir
cette porte et à observer
l'expression de votre inconscient ce
palais de la mémoire rien que pour vous
comme la première fois je vous inviter à
flâner et vous observerez que à chaque
fois vous recommencerez cette séance
d'hypnose d'autres pièces seront
ajoutées peut-être d'autres bâtiments
il n'y a pas de raison pour que vous ne
puissiez pas avoir le plus beau des
ballets et prenez le temps de flâner
prenez le temps de laisser votre
inconscient remplir de détails ce palais
peut-être y aura-t-il un jardin matin
ira-t-il des fontaines peut-être
aurez-vous de dans une salle de cinéma
salle de jeux salle à manger je miné
une piscine pourquoi pas tout est
possible dans le secret et l'intimité de
votre imagination de votre inconscient
n'oubliez pas que dans les moments où
vous avez besoin de vous détendre être
concentré vous pourrez re convoquer ce
palais c'est pour ça que je vous invite
à nouveau à faire un ancrage serré par
exemple l'autre poussé laudrin d'agde
vous puissiez très facilement retrouver
ce palais dès que vous en avez besoin
s'est fait très bien vous pouvez
relâcher cet ancrage et continue encore
quelques instants à flâner et j'invite
votre inconscient a placé ne sont pas
déjà dans chacune de ses pièces un
tableau noir ou un tableau blanche avec
elles s'inscriront des informations que
vous allez retenir qu'ils vont infuser
en vous imprimez rester disponible à
tout moment et même des années après et
maintenant je laissais faire votre
inconscient en totalité pour que dans
chacune des pièces
il illustre
rand concrets sous forme d'image de son
de sensations vos informations
celle que vous devez retenir et vous
pouvez prendre le temps que vous voulez
même si certaines informations de séance
passé n'ont pas été encore intégré des
séances basse et des révisions base et
bien on va pouvoir les illustrer les
intégrer dans votre palais lorsque ceux
ci auront été illustrée rendu réel vous
pourrez soit content et de 1,5 pour
sortir de tence je regardais les yeux
fermés et ensuite vous endormir car on
sait que le sommeil lui aussi permet
d'intégrer les informations et que les
choses que l'on a vécu juste avant de
dormir bien souvent se retrouvent dans
nos rêves alors peu importe le moment de
la journée où ferait cette séance vous
pourrez si vous le souhaitez faire une
sieste après où dormir
pleinement le sommet de la nuit ou
simplement à paris à compter de 1,5 et
sortir de transe parfaitement calme
serein confiant car vous serez quand
vous se trouvent déjà toutes les
informations disponibles très facilement
disponibles si vous souhaitez
recommencer à réviser vous prend de
faire avec une concentration un calme
renouvelé et si vous préférez repartir
dans le courant de votre vie vers
d'autres choses
vous pourrez en profiter plus plane ou
encore une fois avec un calme complet
une confiance forte et je vous
accompagne ainsi l'un tandis que vous
allez orné toutes ces pièces de
merveilleuses connaissances sur sa
compagne incident